so elon musk who it does look like he is  going to get twitter and he has become  one of the most outspoken critics of  this administration and he tweeted that  he is most likely going to well he said  he's going to vote for a republican  going forward but that he would support  ron desantis if he ran for president uh  he's now out there saying that yeah a  recession is on the way  a recession is inevitable at some point  um  as to whether there is a recession in  the near term  um i think that is more likely than not  uh certainly certainly isn't it's not a  certainty but um  it appears more likely than not  personally i tend to trust elon musk  more than anyone who works for the  administration